[Musique]
le monde de la crypto monnaie secoué par
le risque d'effondrement d'une
plateforme d'échanges du nom de FTX
l'entreprise fait face à une grave crise
de liquidité alors qu'elle a besoin de 8
milliards de dollars américains à court
terme pour couvrir les retraits des
investisseurs by non ce qui est la plus
importante plateforme des changes de
crypto du monde c'était montrer
intéressé à acheter FTX avant finalement
d'abandonner avec nous pour en parler
Alexandre Roch qui est professeur en
finance à l'École des sciences de la
gestion du CAM bonsoir bonsoir d'abord
expliquez-nous brièvement qu'est-ce que
FTX qui est au cœur de tous les
tourments en ce moment vous l'avez bien
dit en fait là c'est une plateforme
d'échange électronique sur laquelle les
investisseurs ne peut partout dans le
monde en fait le peuvent s'inscrire
déposer des fonds et donc utiliser ça
pour faire des échanges achetés vendre
des crypto-monnaies puis il y avait même
aussi
impliqué quelques produits dérivés
l'associés à ces crypto monnaie et
pourquoi manque tel de liquidité bon ben
premièrement c'est souvent ça part sur
des dans ce cas-ci je pense c'était
vraiment basé sur des mauvais
investissements ce qui arrive justement
c'est que des clients veulent couramment
juste retirer leur argent
et puis FTX c'était exposé là de
liquider certaines de leurs positions
pour pouvoir payer les investisseurs et
apparemment il y aurait pas
nécessairement de liquidité alors il y a
le fondateur et PDG de FTX se fait appel
à la plus grande plateforme de
d'échanges électroniques comme ça qui
s'appelle bananes qui est beaucoup plus
grosse et que demander de l'aise
essentiellement qui a demandé en fait de
racheter son entreprise là pour essayer
d'injecter quelques quelques liquidités
dans l'entreprise le PDG c'est Sam
bankman free de convoi présentement
et les autorités réglementaires en cas
est également parce qu'on se demande
s'il y a pas eu de détournement de fonds
ce fondateur de FTX avait aussi fonder
un autre fond d'investissement qui était
beaucoup investi dans les crypto monnaie
à La Mède exactement qui avait beaucoup
investi dans les crypto-monnaies
beaucoup fait d'argent et puis ce qu'on
a compris en fait là justement étant
donné que binance avait proposé de
racheter FTX il y avait fait des
vérifications diligentes et ont
essentiellement ouvert les livres
comptables et ont regardé qu'est-ce
qu'il y avait derrière tout ça on fait
un grand bon là exactement que ce sont
rendus compte que les fonds des
investisseurs avaient été mal gérés on
parle de à la Médoc qui aurait acheté
des la crypto monnaie interne de cette
de cette plateforme électronique là et
donc beaucoup de conflits d'intérêt
beaucoup de questions de comptabilité
boiteuse pour dire le féministe dans ce
cas-ci là il y avait beaucoup de et là
on apprend ce soir que les Bahamas sont
gelés les actifs de FTX parce que FTX
est installé au Bahamas ce type
d'entreprise n'a pas le droit de
s'installer aux États-Unis au Canada en
Europe pourquoi ben parce que ça
simplement parce qu'il ne satisfont pas
toute la réglementation qui existe dans
nos pays des réglementations qui
existent justement pour protéger les
investisseurs pour protéger les
déposants première règle c'est quand
quelqu'un dépose sur son argent la
banque postposer de prendre ça puis à
l'investir dans quelque chose de
beaucoup plus risqué c'est ce que FTX
serait fait à ce niveau-là FTX tout à
fait reconnu d'abord que premièrement
était plus capable de rembourser les
investisseurs donc ils ont eux-mêmes
pris l'initiative de tout geler de dire
arrêter de retirer on accepte plus de
fond on en retire plus là les autorités
de Bahamas qui ont dit carrément que vos
actifs financiers aussi on va les geler
alors l'entreprise est complètement
gelée vous savez aussi que ses Coyote
capital qui était un des plus gros
investisseurs là qui est investi dans
cette entreprise là essentiellement
considère que ça vaut plus rien donc
leur investissement de quelques 200
millions de dollars est complètement
perdu est-ce que ça ressemble au cas de
Celsius network dont on a parlé ensemble
également il y a quelques temps oui tout
à fait c'est le même genre de situation
dans laquelle on a essentiellement là
une version moderne d'une panique
bancaire dans lequel des déposants
bon je sais pas si on est-ce qu'on peut
vraiment considérer fait fftx comme
étant une vraie banque mais il faut
essentiellement des activités
commerciales bancaires ou ce qui accepte
des dépôt et donc les gens voient ça
c'est basé sur une mauvaise rumeur ils
veulent tout retirer leur argent en même
temps c'est essentiellement la notion de
panique puis après ça il faut
essentiellement geler les avoir puis
est-ce que tout le monde a perdu tout là
est-ce que les investisseurs ont perdu
leur apparemment
on va le voir là certainement FTX va se
mettre sur la protection de la loi sur
la faillite il va falloir évaluer
justement la valeur de ses actifs là si
c'est vraiment des actifs si on avait
investi leur argent on a des trucs très
risqués comme les crypto monnaie
évidemment
on s'y attend ben là ça ça peut perdre
beaucoup de valeur très peu de temps
donc il va falloir voir essentiellement
donc quel sera et quel est l'effet sur
l'ensemble du monde de la crypto-monnaie
sur l'ensemble pas très gros c'est quand
même peut-être le quatrième ou cinquième
plus grosse plateforme d'échange
électronique mais c'est pas le principal
joueur dans le domaine
à mon avis ça va rester quand même assez
marginal il y a un petit impact sur les
sur les prix des crypto monnaie
certainement que la volatilité c'est
l'incertitude de beaucoup augmenté
depuis quelques jours à cause de ce qui
s'est
produit nouvelle crise de confiance oui
c'est ça c'est toujours des crises de
confiance qui sont associés à Jean
d'événements comme ça malheureusement il
y en a plein d'autres entreprises
privées comme ça et qui ont investi qui
qui
œuvrent dans le domaine des
crypto-monnaies moi je prévois qu'en
Europe c'est pas complètement impossible
qui pourrait en avoir d'autres dans un
futur assez rapproché ça affecte même le
Bitcoin qui est quand même le plus connu
des crypto-monnaies exactement donc
c'est une plateforme sur laquelle on
peut échanger Bitcoin ça donne un effet
de contagion sur toutes les crypto
monnaie qui sont tout un peu reliés
ensemble Alexandra merci pour ces
explications ce soir merci bien merci à
vous pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI